أتذكر أنني كنت أفكر عندما بدأت ،
عندما بدأت علاقة حب مع
القهوة
المثلجة ، أتذكر أنني
عندما ضربتني لأول مرة عندما
شعرت أنها ضربت عقلي
وشعرت أنها انقطعت في عقلي في
التركيز في  بطريقة لم يسبق لها مثيل من
قبل وأتذكر أنني لا أصدق
أن المجتمع
قد قرر للتو في مرحلة
ما ، أنت تعرف ما هي هذه الأدوية ، حسنًا ،
تلك الأدوية الأخرى التي لا نحبها ولكن
القهوة نعم ،
لا هذا جيد تمامًا أشعر أنني
يعني عندما أدرجت في كتاب
إلى جانب الأفيون
والميسكالين ، شعرت بأنني مبرر
لأنه على الرغم من أنهما مختلفان بوضوح ،
لكنني أعني أنني أشعر أن القهوة
هي وهم
جماعي لأننا نتظاهر فقط ، لا لا
، إنه ليس دواءً ،
نعم لا  أنا وهذا هو بالضبط
سبب رغبتي في إدراجه
في كتاب عن الأدوية النباتية ، لا
نفكر فيه على أنه دواء نعتقد
أنه طعام
أو شراب ولكنه في الحقيقة
دواء وكما اكتشفت  واحد قوي
ومفيد جدا  بالمناسبة ،
أنا لست ضد القهوة بأي حال من الأحوال
وأنا فضولي نوعًا ما على الرغم من أنه كان
لديك
طريقة أخرى لإعطاء الكافيين
لجسمك
فعلت ذلك على الرغم من أنني لم أفكر أبدًا
أنه شعرت به على أنه  الكافيين الشيء
الثاني كان أه لا يشرب الكوكاكولا ، نعم ،
كنت أشرب الكولا العادية ثم
تحولت إلى فحم الكوك الحمية ثم فحم الكوك ،
لكنني أدركت كما لو كنت تعلم
أنه يحتوي على أشياء مثل
المحليات وهذا على الأرجح ليس جيدًا  من
أجل عقلي ، لقد تعرفت صديقي الطبيب على
طبيب أعصاب
قال لي أنك تعرف ما الذي يجب أن
تتناوله من القهوة السوداء المثلجة
لأنني لا أحب الأشياء الساخنة
وهو أذكى طبيب في
العالم أعني وأه نعم أنا  يعني ذلك ما الذي
يفعله الكافيين
مثل ما هو الكافيين والقهوة
مختلفًا عن لأنني أعني
أنني لا أصدق أننا نعطي
الكافيين لأطفالنا لا أصدق عندما
كنت طفلاً كنت أشرب المشروبات الغازية طوال الوقت
الذي تعرفه  ستة من أفضل 10 مشروبات صودا في
أمريكا
تحتوي على الكافيين أه  لماذا يضعون
الكافيين في تلك المشروبات الغازية لأنه لا
يحدث بشكل طبيعي بالطريقة
التي تحدث بشكل طبيعي في القهوة والشاي
جيدًا ، والسبب في قيامهم بذلك هو
بيع المزيد
منه وإدمان الأطفال ، إنها فضيحة أن
هذا هو  مسموح به
ولكن كان هناك محاولة
لتنظيمه منذ بضع سنوات ، لكن
الصناعة تغلبت عليه ، زعموا أنهم
يستخدمون الكافيين
لإعطاء ملاحظة مريرة للنكهة ، لكن
الكثير من العلم أظهر أنه
في الواقع السبب الحقيقي هو
الكافيين هو معزز لأي مشروب
يحتوي على مادة الكافيين ستنمي
معه ارتباطات إيجابية
، وبالتالي فإن طعم القهوة
الذي يعجبك ،
تخمين ما هو مرير جدًا بالفعل
وأنت تعلم أن هناك الكثير من السلبيات
حول مذاق القهوة
ولكن نظرًا لأنه مرتبط الآن
بهذا الشعور الرائع ، فإنه
يمنحك طعمًا رائعًا أيضًا
والرائحة وهذا ما يفعله المعزز
حتى أنك تتحدث عنه لا
يزال يجعلني أكثر قفزًا  ومتحمسًا
لذلك بالنسبة لمعظمنا ، تكتب أنك
تكتب في الكتاب الذي تكتبه
لمعظمنا لتناول الكافيين بدرجة أو
بأخرى ، فقد أصبح ببساطة
وعيًا بشريًا أساسيًا
مثل 90
شخصًا يتناولون الكافيين بانتظام مما يجعل
أكثر الأدوية ذات التأثير النفساني استخدامًا  في
العالم والوحيدة التي نعطيها في الأصل
للأطفال شكلاً شائعًا
من الصودا أم ما الذي
يفعله الكافيين
لما يشبه هذا الشعور مثل عقلي
من النقر حقًا على ما
يفعله الكافيين بدماغ
المرء جيدًا  الكثير من التأثيرات
لها نوع من الرفع الذي تحصل عليه من
إطلاق الدوبامين
أه الذي تقدمه الكثير من الأدوية
وقد يكون وربما يكون له علاقة
بإدمانه أيضًا على الرغم من أنه يحجب
ناقلًا عصبيًا معينًا أو معدلًا عصبيًا
يسمى الأدينوزين وهو مادة كيميائية
في  جسمك الذي
يتراكم على مدار اليوم
ويجعلك تشعر بالتعب تدريجيًا
ومن الضروري أن تجعلك تنام
أه الكافيين
يناسب نفس الاستقبال  أو
يمنع الأدينوزين من أن يكون له أي تأثير
على الرغم من أن مستوياته تستمر في الارتفاع في
عقلك وهذا هو السبب في أنه عندما
يتلاشى الكافيين ، فإنك تحصل على هذا النوع من التعب الارتدادي ،
لذلك
لا يمنحك الكافيين في الواقع
طاقة إضافية ،
فإنه يستعير الطاقة من المستقبل بشكل
أساسي ولكن
إنها تمتلك هذه التأثيرات الأخرى التي لا
نفهمها جيدًا ، على سبيل المثال ،
الإحساس القوي بالتركيز الذي تحصل عليه منه
والذي
تعرف القدرة على تركيز
اه التحسينات في الذاكرة
وقد أجرينا اختبارات إذا درست
شيئًا ما أو تقرأ كتابًا أو تستوعب بعض
المواد
أو تعرف التحضير لمقابلة
إذا تناولت القهوة بعد الانتهاء من ذلك ،
فمن المرجح أن تحتفظ بها ،
إنها تحسن الأداء لدى الرياضيين
والقدرة على التحمل ،
لذا فهي تحتوي على كل هذه الأشياء.
تأثيرات
إيجابية ولكن في بعض الأشخاص الذين تعلمون أنه
يصبح مخدرًا للإساءة ،
فأنت تعرف أشخاصًا يتناولون ستة أكواب وسبعة وثمانية
أكواب في اليوم